Hey, Crystal, good morning.
Ayra, good morning. How are you?
I'm doing great this Monday. How about you? How are you today?
Oh, it's been pretty busy. Thanks for asking.
All right, Monday. It's always busy on Mondays. All right. Are we ready to proceed?
Yes.
Let me just quickly share my screen here. Let me know once it's visible.
Yes, I can see it now.
Okay, perfect. By the way, we have Justin joining our call today, but then he's just going to be observing us. Justin, if you have questions, feel free to let us know, okay?
Thanks, Ayra. Hi, Crystal. Nice to meet you again.
Thank you. Same here.
Okay, cool. Thank you. So thank you, Justin and Crystal, for joining our bi-weekly service call. Today, we're going to be reviewing the performance of John from April 20 to May 1st. Moving on to the agenda items. This is all the same. Check in and update highlights, performance analysis, and open Q&A.
Go ahead.
Moving on to the check-in slide, this is for you, Crystal. How are things at this moment? This is your time to share your feedback for John Matthew.
Everything is going well. There has been a few challenges as it relates to the tickets that he's worked on. One in particular on Friday, he reached out concerning a client where he mentioned that he didn't have access to their Office 365.
He didn't reach out to me to inquire about it. He pretty much reached out to another person on the team. But I did advise to him, you know, whenever there's a situation, please reach out to me. But I do believe he said that he did, but I just didn't get his notification or something of that matter.
Okay, I'll make sure that he's fully aware of the proper escalation, especially with this L1 tickets. May I know if there are any pending access or is it something that he should have access to for the Microsoft ticket?
Well, I don't know if you recall, there are some clients that we currently have on-prem, which our network security engineer is working to get him access for those clients. But for the other clients, he definitely should have access with the Office 365 total that we provided for him.
Mm.
Okay. I'll look into that one too. Okay. All righty. So I'll have that checked right away so I can let you know if there's still other clients that he can't access, but then he should have so that we can look into it further. But then apart from that, Crystal, are there any other issues or challenges?
What a portal access, sorry. Okay.
No other issues. I'll work with him a little bit more also as it relates to other tickets that I'm certain that he can work on.
Okay, perfect. Also, if you need any help on my end, you can always ping me so I can look into it, okay?
Sure, thank you.
You're welcome. Moving on to it, it's the performance analysis. Here we go.
For the ITBD recommended KPIs, Crystal, you're already aware of this. If you have questions for this one, let me know so we can discuss further.
For the operational readiness flow, I can see that we've already completed all of the things here, especially for the operational solo. Since he's already working on L1 tickets, I've been seeing his email. He's been including all of the supported tickets for L1s that he's been working on. That's very good.
Starting next service call, I'll be including all the L1 tickets here on our deck so we can see if he's hitting the target.
For Build It Live, Crystal, we will be having it on August 3 to 5. Is this something you want to visit or you want to join?
No, I'm good. Thank you.
Okay. But then if you're interested, please let us know if you want to join this tremendous event. All of our leads would be there. So if you have questions for this, I have Justin here. He can answer it for you. Okay?
And then moving on to the other ITBD by design products that we have. It's still the same as discussed on our previous service call. If you are interested in any of these, please let us know.
For the way forward, I have checked your calendar and on May 25th, it's your, it's a holiday on your end, right? So we don't need John Matthew to log in.
I'll need to confirm whether if we're open. I don't believe whether if we were closed, those signs are open.
Rubiku song.
Okay.
Mhm.
Sorry, cutting in and out, Crystal.
Hello?
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can hear you now.
Hello, OK. Sorry, I was in a bad service area.
It's okay.
Let me know if you're still having difficulties or if we can proceed.
Oh, yes, yes, I can hear you now.
Oh, perfect. So as we were discussing, I heard that you're going to check if John Matthew will be required on May 25th.
Yes, most of our clients are open, so I'll need to confirm whether we're open that day, but I believe we are, but I'll let you know before the end of the day.
Okay, thank you so much for that. And for the last item here, we, IT by Design, continues to provide you with a reliable coverage for your daily operations, especially for after hours, ensuring seamless triage and dispatch, especially we've added L1,
Yeah.
tickets to Matthew and moving on to the next quarter, since you're planning to add him to a new project. So that's also one thing that we can add value to your company.
That's the same slide. And yeah, this is the end of my slide, Crystal. Is there anything else you want to bring up on this service call?
No, that's it for now. I appreciate that.
Okay, I'll stop sharing my screen. And thank you once again for joining our bi-weekly service call. If you have any urgent matters to discuss, feel free to ping me, okay?
I.
Thank you, Ayra.
You're welcome. Have a great day, Crystal. Bye bye.
Thank you. Bye-bye.
Thanks, Crystal. Bye for now.
Bye bye.